the balance of risk is very strongly
in favor of children actually going to
school
because many more are likely to be
harmed by not going
[Music]
[Applause]
it was a risk to reopen but one
this government was willing to take
covert cases rose
children were sent home some schools had
to shut
again in this second national lockdown
they are excluded
and education will continue but the
largest body representing teachers in
england
believes it's a huge mistake we wouldn't
want schools completely closed we think
they should be open to key workers to
the
the children of nhs staff or tesco
delivery drivers
and to vulnerable kids but we think that
by and large
for this four week period it would be
more sensible if primary and secondary
schools were closed
whilst it's been a challenging period
for this school in blackpool
the teachers here want to carry on
working to provide vital education
it almost feels like head teachers are
almost being expected to come up with
their own solution to what's a national
challenge yes the government give
guidance every day 40 page documents
every day to read
but it would be useful if there was a
national strategy on how
on how best um to move forward with
education
for schools across the country there
remains a fine line
between protecting the health of its
staff and
students and ensuring educational
development
for many it's a tough battle to contend
with
after last night's announcement the mood
amongst parents is mixed
i think skills are probably the worst
thing in the world to be open at the
moment is it
above their elf that's what you got to
look at i mean
you can be intelligent as you want to
learn as much as you want but if your
elf's not there then what's it worth
i'm confident that if it did become a
risk that they would do what they did
earlier in the year and close the
schools and we'd go back to
homeschooling
um so we've just got to sort of see how
things pan out really
it's not going to slow spread the virus
keeping schools open
you sure somebody you shot it all in
front of pending him for a pound
unlike many occasions during this
pandemic the labour leader is supporting
the prime minister
to keep schools open but the mayor of
greater manchester
thinks otherwise if we are to break
transmission
it will require a period of closure and
i would suggest
a period of two weeks closure towards
the second half of november
there's no denying that it's been a
crushing year for education
many are now having to play catch up but
there still remains
uncertain times ahead from political
disagreements
to a virus that continues to spread what
teachers and students hope
is that there's some light at the end of
this very dark tunnel
in saman rashid sky news in blackpool